you can see we'll be starting in about
four minutes
and we'll be talking about
the data science
boot camp today
foreign
about two minutes away
we're coming up on 9 30 a.m Pacific time
12 30 p.m eastern time in North America
the time is counting down
foreign
very soon
thank you
all right
recording in progress
audience
welcome to everyone on LinkedIn live
and
uh Zoom YouTube live
and Welcome to our live look at the data
science boot camp from Caltech Center
for technology and management
partnership with IBM I'm Stuart Creek I
am with simply learn and we are the
delivery partner for this program for
Caltech
gonna hear a little bit today from a
couple of people
uh Mike Ash Who is the
Caltech ctme director education he is
uh got over 25 years of experience in
the industry and he oversees
Caltech ctme's new programs including
this one
you'll also hear from shubham Pandi who
is one of our senior instructors in data
science
and he'll be sharing with you how the
funding management system works so
we're going to cover a few things about
you about data science careers what this
program offers how it gets your job
ready
we'll talk about enrollment steps
interested and we'll cover your
questions and answers so if you have
questions please put them into the Q a
function
and zoom or into your chat or comment
box in your streaming service
and we'll see if we can get to those at
the end of the presentation here so
with that I am going to
share with you
Mike Ash's comments
so let's talk a little bit about
careers and in data science so
you know
not only has this been
popular and everyone already knows that
but the amount of data that is out there
is is staggering I mean you can't even
really wrap your head around it
175 zettabytes uh is
more than I could imagine a lot of that
is a video a lot of that is an
unstructured text a lot of that is in
structured data and we all need ways of
understanding what that is what are the
patterns how do we use this whether
we're using it for science or we're
using it for business or other
applications
um it's a a huge field and maybe some of
you on this webinar today are
looking at changing your career to move
into the field
um if you're already a technologist and
you want to expand what you're doing and
we'll talk a little bit about how this
might be relevant for you
some of the many roles across data
science that this program is going to be
relevant for
um include people who want to be the
data scientist who want to be a better
analyst
architect information
um architect Technologies
um
applying machine learning and and
business intelligence and visualization
to commercial problems
perhaps you want to get into statistics
uh with a you know for research or
business
and just being an overall kind of
analytics engineer and that is more than
just the Technologies but it's the
communications it's being able to
understand what is this data telling us
what does it mean and and whether or not
we should act on it
and so these are many roles are
available in almost any kind of company
and if you're pursuing these kinds of
roles there are a number of skills that
you need to excel in and one boot Camp's
not going to give you everything you
can't be an expert just by finishing but
in a comprehensive program like ours
that you're going to cover many of these
things and you're going to know a
substantial
uh fortunate in order to land that job
or operate successfully in the role
right so it you already need to be kind
of clever and come in with an
understanding of math and and basic
statistics but what you're going to get
into here to build skills is more around
what is it what kind of data do we need
to solve problems how do I get that
how do I manipulate that data
um how do I get it ready to perform
certain analyzes
is it something that we can apply
machine learning to
how do we train that machine learning
um
how do we package all that together and
whether we're scripting or coding or
using python
we'll have to get into those things
um and so having that kind of broader
analytical thinking and critical
thinking you also need to bring
um
your skills and the scientific method
having a hypothesis finding the data and
and
solving those problems proven or
disproving those hypotheses
whether it's for business experiments or
research or other
we're going to work on
making you
a better analytical thinker
all right
so that's a little bit of the background
for the program
and I'm going to ask a first poll
question
are you in the audience
if you're on the streaming service
But A B C or D in your
chat or comment box
but what has stopped you so far from
taking this type of certification in
data science
we're all here in this audience today
for
your interest in the field so
is there
a reason or two that you haven't done
this so far
we'll leave this open
only this open for about another 10
seconds as you get your answers in
okay and I'll close the poll in about
five
or
four three
two
one
so the two top reasons that people cited
are not feeling that they would end up
with practical experience that they
could use to demonstrate their new
skills to their employer or to a future
employer and then also not finding time
within their work schedules or working
professional to be able to do this type
of
training and education so
we'll talk about that in the context of
the Caltech ctme Caltech Center for
technology and management education
data science boot camp this is a seven
month program
um
say it takes about five to ten hours of
effort per week
this program is uh
delivered by simply learn and uh the
curriculum is established by Caltech in
collaboration with IBM so there's going
to be components that are delivered by
IBM as well
and it is a comprehensive curriculum the
Celtic has designed this to be aligned
with the needs of industry and what
they've heard from companies that they
require from people in data science
successful and
to make a good contribution to their
companies
um it's delivered entirely online this
program
is available to you from your desktop or
laptop computer much of the material uh
quarter parts of it can be accessed on
your mobile device
so it's really available to you anywhere
anytime 24x7
and you
incorporates both the online live
virtual classrooms which happen
generally speaking on weekends four
hours Saturday four hour Sunday
so that you can fit those into your work
schedule but also um
it includes integrated Labs Hands-On
projects for practical experience things
that you will do on the platform you
don't need to switch out or acquire a
different set of Hardware software all
available to you right there in the
integrated platform and
available to you 24x7 so
this is a program that you can fit to
your work schedule your life schedule
and complete in seven months
all online
the end of the program you're going to
get a number of different things one is
the certificate from Caltech
which certifies that you've completed
the boot camp program and all of the
core classes successfully uh you'll get
certificates along the way for the
different classes including ones that
have been delivered by IBM so each of
those if you take those electives or IBM
classes IBM will issue certificates as
well you'll be doing more than two dozen
Hands-On projects
in integrated labs and you'll receive
the opportunity to take master classes
from both Caltech ctme instructors and
from IBM instructors
you'll get exclusive hackathons and AMA
sessions from IBM
which allow you to work with folks who
are working in industry and get their
perspective and
get some exposure to that you'll receive
up to 14 CEUs from Caltech ctme if you
are in a a job that requires you to
certify to your employer or to a
licensing body or a regulatory agency
that you are taking
continuing education
the CEUs are you're proof of that so
that's a valuable benefit you also
receive membership in the online Caltech
ctme Circle
which is a
networking and career
uh
Alumni Association for people who've
taken the Celtic ctme professional
programs
and you'll get recognized that an online
convocation which you can invite friends
and family to so that they can see you
get called out and recognized for your
achievement
um all this is offered
by Caltech California Institute of
Technology it's been around for over 130
years
it is a privately run institution not
run by the state of California
um it's
become recently famous because of The
Big Bang Theory television program
they decided to set it at Caltech
because they wanted a show about
extremely drilling into people and Bell
Tech is where you find a whole lot of
those number of people who have won
Nobel prizes both for the research at
Caltech and for the research elsewhere
and then have come to Caltech to
continue their research
um so it is a
vibrant institution it consistently
ranks the top five of universities
worldwide and having that name on your
resume or CV is really uh
recognized achievement that people will
notice
we're also very proud of the affiliation
we have with IBM I mentioned you have
the opportunity for hackathons and ask
me anything sessions master classes with
IBM instructors
and you'll earn certificates along the
way for courses or our programming or
python
programming
so this is a additional very valuable
benefit of this program
we talk about the eligibility
intercourse the prerequisites rather I'm
sorry for this program
you must have some prior knowledge or
experience in programming and math
um
to be 18 years of age
or older with a high school diploma
this is not a postgraduate program so
you don't have to have a bachelor's
degree
um we prefer you to have two or more
years of experience in any formal job
that so you understand
the needs of of organizations and what
their needs around data
maybe and it is not a hard and fast
requirement however
with that information I'm going to ask
another question just to get a feel for
who's in our audience today
so how much experience do you currently
have are you currently studying
uh maybe working towards your bachelor's
degree
um are you in the workforce
and how long have you been in the
workforce
this is a pretty straightforward
question I'm just going to leave it open
for another 10 seconds
and I'll close it in five four three
two
one
well about 20 of our audience or folks
who are still in school
um the rest of you have more experience
including a large number
with more than five years of experience
so fairly seasoned group
on to how this program prepares you and
this is where I'm going to um
ask
or share with you what Shivam has shared
with us previously so
chip and Pandy one of our senior
instructors
this is where I'm going to um
let shim present to you the learning
environment the learning management
system
sure
thanks to Stewart
let me share my screen for that
and he'll give us a bit of a tour of
what the experience is like for learners
my screen is visible to all of you
yes it is
great thank you
so this is uh how your learning
management system would look like when
you will log into your LMS LMS when I
say I mean learning management system
so learning management system is
basically a One-Stop shop for you for
all your learning requirements
so I'll just take you through this
learning management system ID to I guess
refresh my page
here you go
so
uh here here I have these programs I
have enrolled for I'm a trainer so
I'm enrolled into multiple programs
so I'll go to one of these programs say
post graduate program in Ai and machine
learning I'll click here on this tab go
to program
so in this program we've got these all
courses course one welcome class for
Purdue AI machine learning program it is
for Pardo so I just opened that that was
handy that was ready for me uh PGA
python for data science then you've got
data science with python machine
learning so all these courses are given
here
uh in a very structured manner so that
if you start from scratch even if you
don't know anything you can start from
scratch and then you can get to the Acme
of this particular Zone this particular
field
so if you click on any of these courses
you will land into this page
okay
so this is a self-learning uh course
here you have these self-paced videos so
there are some of some there are some
self-learning courses there are some
instructor driven courses the idea is to
give you the holistic learning
so I just opened the self learning now
I'll open the instructed let course so
here you have everything
so this is a course machine learning
so here you've got these self-paced
videos lesson wise in a very well
structured way
these are the self-paced videos so
before you go for the class before you
go for the live class you can prepare
yourself
you can get yourself ready with the uh
overview of that particular subject
that will give you an edge in the class
you'll be able to discuss better with
the
instructor
you can join your classes through live
class tab
okay
this is a practice lab this is a
cloud-based lab so you don't require to
install any tool you can work on
cloud-based environment so this is
an environment in which you will work in
real life as well so when you work in
this environment you get ready
for any corporate work to work in any
analytics team so the idea is to make
you industry ready so we make you work
in those environments where you make
yourself comfortable
and you work as if you're working in the
real life
project environment
then you've got assessment here here
you've got projects so many of you are
asking about the experience about the
application part so here we have the
projects
which are very close to real life
situations so you'll get to work on
these projects
and you will be evaluated on these
and once you will be done with the
project summation
unless you uh qualify all the criterias
you can unlock your certificate that's
how it is
it does not end here here we also have
community
okay so on this community forum
you can interact uh with the students
uh with the batchmates and with your
faculty you can share your thoughts here
you can share your ideas here you can
ask your questions here
uh on this platform
files can be shared so this community is
also very useful for the learning
purpose
so this is all you have apart from that
you also have all the content in the
form of uh PDF in the form of data sets
because the way of training is case
study based so we uh all the trainers
that simply learn we follow case study
based approach of training because we
all know that it's not about only
learning mathematics it's not only about
learning programming
it's about how you apply
the learning into solving real life
problems right so we focus on
application part and that's why we
follow case study approach and we make
my our students work on different types
of projects from different Industries
so this is all about the LMS steward
great and I'm going to ask you to show
them a little bit later about the
Capstone project and and the importance
of that but then that's the
the final
part of the program that um all the
other courses lead up to and we'll talk
about that in a couple moments oh yes
that is very important so we'll talk
about that as well
so let's talk a little bit about
all right so we've gone through the
learning environment
um showing you how you manage your
curriculum keep track of your classes
how the system prompts you to stay on
track and
move from success to success a little
bit about the live virtual classroom the
tests and projects
and
now I'm going to talk about how this
program builds up your skills step by
step sorry
so the program curriculum is
designed to take you from the basics on
to more advanced topics
so
we
look at
initial session is an orientation that
shows you how to use the learning
management system what to expect what
are the components of your curriculum
well the thing basic virtual freshman
orientation so to speak then the first
course is statistics Essentials for data
science
the underpinnings of data science from
the perspective of
how the data is distributed in the real
world what the different distributions
and mean and how you can
extract inferences from them then we
could move into our programming for data
science
and python for data science so you learn
the programming tools that you'll need
in order to access manipulate and
extract meaning from data
um then once you have that under your
belt you have applied data science
with python using those tools in order
to
um
look at different
problems in different cases and
see how data science applies in each of
those
you have to learn by doing in that
course
you'll move on to machine learning
which is how data models can train
themselves once they get more data and
finally onto Tableau because an
important part of data science is being
able to tell the story of the data and
communicate that to end users you may
not understand data science but we want
to see how
um what the data is telling them
you need to be able to use that type of
visualization tool and then you move
into the industry-based Capstone project
in which you tie all of these new skills
together
to solve
industry aligned problem
that you build the solution for and that
becomes part of your permanent portfolio
along the way you can take electives at
your discretion based on your time
availability and your level of interest
you can study business analytics with
Excel
get background in SQL
database you can look into Microsoft
power bi
you can
start learning more about deep learning
with tensorflow and of course you have
the master classes with IBM and Caltech
instructors
that you can take so
along the way you're going to use a
number of different tools and when I say
use them it means
when you when you use them in this
program you have to demonstrate
proficiency and solve problems using
these tools
have to be able to say I know how to use
Python language I know to use this the
scipy library
interesting on
mind mapping framework
so all of these tools
you demonstrate and again tie together
in your Capstone project
into the process when you list these on
your resume or CV you won't just be
saying that you've been exposed to them
you'll be able to demonstrate that you
know how to
use each of them
and work with them
and of course we've mentioned many times
this Capstone project
you get to pick out of several different
industry domains a problem that
interests you that you would like to
solve a problem in data science and you
get three to four weeks to work on that
problem and create a solution
to build it up from scratch you work
under the guidance of one of your
instructors who will meet with you
weekly and make sure that you're not
calling Anthony
rabbit holes or dead ends and once you
finish this project it becomes part of
your permanent portfolio so not only is
it graded
for this uh
program so that you can earn your
certificate it's also part of your
permanent portfolio to show off
the future employers or to your current
employer to demonstrate that yes you now
have
a new set of skills in data science
uh the program director for this course
is uh
Rick Hefner and he has been working in
the industry and academics for over 40
years
um he oversees Caltech Center for
technology and management education
and
he supervises the curriculum for this
program make sure it meets Caltech
standards and is delivered according to
those standards
but we can talk a little bit about
learner outcomes
so
here the
different batches of people that had
gone through this program they've come
from
various Industries not just from
Information Technology and software but
also from banking financial and
Industrial and other Industries because
every company every industry requires
uh data science and the use of data and
understanding the insights from data so
you will
probably see people from other companies
like Amazon and Microsoft and Banks like
Barclays and Wells Fargo and Industrial
companies like Bosch and
consultancies like as Accenture
uh all of these types of people will be
in the same batch as you
um this course so you never know who
you're going to rub up against or who
you're going to be able to network with
among your batchmates
we also offer or Learners in the US and
this is a U.S oriented program
from caltex so this one
offers career service to U.S Learners
that
comprises
expert webinars and career events that
simply when puts on that are are free
and available to you uh for
on an ongoing basis
to know end date on those
um you have of course the projects that
I mentioned
including the Capstone project that
become your portfolio to demonstrate
your capabilities and we have formal job
assist services in association with
Talent Inc
which extend for six months
after the
time you earn your certificate so
Talent Inc gives you access to three
main
Services one is the job portal they call
resume rabbit which gives you access to
exclusive job listings that they have
through their employer Network
allow you to apply to those discreetly
and confidentially
I think the other two parts of the
service are even more valuable
resume review and rewrite which
allows you to
craft a new version of your resume in
Junction with a professional
and the reason that's important is
because today resumes go through
automated tracking Services the first
thing that happens is they passed
through an AI bot that Compares them to
job descriptions
filters out anything that doesn't
adequately match so
first thing you need to have help with
is crafting a resume that is compatible
with and understandable by those
tracking systems and AI Bots
that way it will get through the filter
you have the best chance of getting
through that filter getting in front of
a human being and then that's the second
part of the resume rewrite review is to
make sure your resume is still
attractive to the human eye when it gets
onto somebody's screen or desktop and so
um you being able to do both of those
things in the same resume is an art form
writer will be helping you with that
um
you also get one-on-one interview
service
preparation for interviews
because if you get through the filter
and get your resume in front of somebody
who then wants to talk to you you'll
have telephone screening interviews with
HR you'll have
technical interviews with subject matter
experts the manager who will be actually
supervising your work and then you'll
have
culture cultural fit and management fit
interviews with
team leaders who want to make sure that
you
um
a good fit culturally a good team player
somebody who can make a good
contribution to their organization so
all those different types of interviews
you'll get a chance to practice in
one-on-one with an interview
consultant
that will help you to put your best foot
forward in your job search and this is
not a job guarantee program this is a
job search assistance program that helps
you with that job search
as I mentioned the expert webinars that
let you look at
different aspects of the industry what's
out there what are the new trends
um
if you're coaching on
career skills like how to use a job
board or how to plan out your career
and here's some examples of the projects
you'll be doing in this program
Mobility is a service using a
that would be like a lifter or Uber and
being able to um use data for the fair
prediction modeling
automobile manufacturing being able to
optimize manufacturing and testing or
retail being able to
look at
possible effects of different
discount strategies and that type of
thing so
these are real world problems that
companies have to solve and you'll be
challenged to pick one and solve it with
your own approach
be able to defend that
uh
when it's created
So based on what I've shared with you
today
so far
are you interested
enrolling in this boot camp
foreign
for about 20 seconds total
that'll be another 10 seconds
and I'll close it in five four three two
one
so 90 of our respondents said that
you're interested in
enrolling in this program which is great
I will share with you how to do that
when Roman steps are straightforward and
I will put into the
chat right now
both the link to the program page access
our learning Consultants by that page
but you can also email us directly at
ask us at simply learn
dot net
put that into the chat for everybody
so
you send us a contact us we'll send you
the application information
we'll send you a test to assess your
programming in mathematical knowledge
and aptitude just to make sure that you
have the basics for this program
and we'll look at your work history
and then
if you qualify we will send you
an admission offer
get started now when you get started you
can start as early as tomorrow with an
induction
um there are going to be other induction
sessions a little bit later in the month
as well but the next set of classes
starts March 1st if you want to get
started that quickly
um
the pro program is again designed for
North America Latin America so it's
denominated in US Dollars eight thousand
dollars
total groups total cost
and you can
do 12-month no interest financing for
that 704 dollars a month also we
recommend that if you have a
lawyer with a tuition reimbursement
policy that you contact them ask your
Learning and Development or HR
department
about what their tuition reimbursement
policy is and see if they will help you
defray some of this cost
again reach out to us and ask us
simplylearn.net
and help you get started
quick question how soon
those of you who are interested how soon
would you like to start
I always say that if this is something
that is going to improve your life and
your career
uh it's always
better to start it sooner than later
I will leave this open for another 15
seconds or so
foreign
poor
re
one
share the results
so about fifty percent of you want to
start either in the marked classes or
the ones in April or May coming right
after
um which is great for the remainder of
you uh please contact us at ask us
simplylearn.net
and we'll keep you informed about future
cohorts starting and also we'll answer
any final questions
um might have about the program but
right now I'm going to see if I can
take the questions out of the Q a
quick look
at the moment
looking here
just scrolling through I'll do
was that four hours both Saturday and
Sunday every weekend so for the the
duration of the program
not every single weekend but almost
every weekend not all the courses are
um have that live component but you
should
plan to go into this program making your
weekends available for that it's usually
morning hours
on the west coast afternoon hours on the
East Coast
um but yeah you you need to be able to
attend a majority of those classes if
you miss some
you will be able to catch up on the
recording of those
how do you create an account on this
platform when you enroll
contact our learning consultants in the
world they will create the account for
you and give you credentials for it
um
look
is the program available in Spanish too
the program is not currently available
in Spanish although we were look we are
looking at that for the future because
we are expanding our offerings in Latin
America
and
moving to
bertana asks I am new to this field do I
need experience you do not have to have
experience in the field for saying that
you should have some background in
programming and Mathematics so you
should have had
some experience and
writing simple programs or
got that background that's
that's fine and again we will assess
that
contact us
uh
Anonymous attendee asks is there a way
for a prospective student with no stem
background
to quickly get prepared to take part in
a program like this
and the answer to that is Yes actually
if you guess the learning Consultants
they can point you to a number of
pre-courses that simply learn offers
um
that can give you the basic backgrounds
in
simple statistical principles
mathematical principles and in in
programming
so you can do some self-study courses
like that that will get you ready for
this program so
please do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net about that
um
I have no experience in coding
it's me as a pack
is the the name on this account uh I no
experience in coding but have a minor in
mathematics at my bachelor's level from
Pakistan I'm looking to get in the field
to keep my skills cup relevant
would this be a helpful course in
getting jobs in international markets so
the answer to that is yes you have no
experience in coding but as I just
mentioned we have
free courses that can get you a
basic grounding in that so you will be
able to
um
get started in that so I would contact
our
Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net for that
uh nor asks are the lectures
pre-recorded lectures are not
pre-recorded the live virtual classes
not pre-recorded
a live virtual classes
happen live
interact with the instructor they'll ask
you questions you'll ask them questions
those sessions are recorded for your
review later on or if you happen to miss
a weekend
but um those are live classes there is
pre-recorded material I think
Sherman mentioned that there are some
pre-recorded uh self-study material that
of course may have where the instructor
says watch these before the next class
section session so that you understand
what I'm going to talk about so that's
part of your your homework in between
Class sessions
um
Anonymous attendee who is asking for the
recorded video and we will be sending a
link to this recording uh in an email
after this session
and
what is the placement rate with
employers can that be broken down by age
I would ask that of the learning
Consultants they do have those
statistics we need to keep those
statistics
um we have a certified
study done by a consulting firm with
Ernst Young
ey
said that 90 percent of our
simply learned program
learners
achieve their objective when they
complete the course so again ask us ask
us to simplylearn.net and we will be
able to
share with you some specific answers to
that question
um what is the difference between the
data science masters course from Simply
learn and this boot camp
and the difference
one of the biggest differences is your
exposure to Caltech
um
name of of the institution on your
resume when you when you complete and
the fact that Caltech
oversees this program and mentors it and
gives you access to Caltech master
classes that's
big added value Factor there so
again you can ask our learning
Consultants about the difference between
the programs
um but we we feel that
this program
well justifies its price
um so with that
I am basically at the end
of
the
questions and answers that have come in
so far
so I'm going to move on to the last
question for you in the audience
I find the right place to go
here we go
here we're going to ask this the
question uh
and
if you are interested by the way in
getting a certificate
of attendance for this session tonight
today rather
um
please answer yes we can send you a
proof of attendance certificate all it
signifies is that you were here
but if that's of interest to you or
value to you send that to you
and then if you're interested if you
need assistance from our learning
Consultants to get enrolled please
answer yes
we'll help you
I'll leave this open for another five
seconds since it's a yes or no question
I closed the poll now
and 50 50 split
so again we
invite all of you to contact us and ask
us at simplywin.net that QR code will
take you to
the program page on our website
and
um
very glad to help you answer any
questions you have
that you lined up for
uh the next cohort or the one that fits
your schedule most conveniently
on behalf of Simply learn and Caltech I
want to
offer you our wish that you join us in
the Caltech and simply learn learning
community
and I want to offer our sincere thanks
for your spending your time with us this
morning so
um
that
include the webinar
hope to see you soon
foreign